what's your problem [ __ ] is your problem
today no energy today man Jewish last
name I know but to think about your
energy right now dude is it maybe my
diet what's going on
I've been eating less than 1800 calories
a day yeah you let me roll in your eyes
yeah like your eyes are dark are you
still doing intermittent and on top of
1810 well the only reason for the 1800s
is just because I hate bad last week's
is just Theresa are you eating 1800 like
real good calories or you know they're
good they're good they're all vegetables
Gilbert
if you you don't look healthy that's
what it is your energy look at the bags
in your is it dark you're not doing
you're just from just rubbing my eyes no
no you have never look at how swollen
and dark his eyes are right now he looks
fine oh my god I'd shake it blood work
no you look like you're on the last
stages of some sort of disease be me
yeah you know Dante she made me do
vegetarians yeah I didn't I'm I just
started myself just to kind of cuz I had
a lot of pride oh I said to her I go in
what was the other night I go oh yeah I
wanted to go the Korean barbecue with
Steve and I go can I have it she's like
well you know it's up to you I go well
will you give me [ __ ] if I eat meat is
that well you said you were gonna do it
so but you know it's your decision
mm-hmm it's true so when you Snow
reversing in that way you're like oh I
can't do it hmm this is how this is cool
hey baby I'm gonna go eat you know what
sweetie you did eight days you know go
ahead you need a little reward right and
I know coming dude I need all right
so what I'm saying to you right now is
that if you want me to if you're cool
with it then you say I'm cool with it
but don't give me psychological [ __ ]
with it now because I I told you that
this is a commitment that we made
together because I can't do this [ __ ]
alone if cuz I cook for you right and if
I have to cook meat for you that [ __ ] is
difficult so I want to live it so badly
when I was a sailor I didn't I [ __ ]
he ate like Caesars nine Caesar salad
you know and I was hoping I didn't ask
but I'm sure those anchovies in the
[ __ ] sauce so you still eat cheese
and dairy and stuff yeah but still do
have you not have you gone like a week
without eating me I don't eat me I just
need I just eat fish oh oh oh you're
pescetarian yes six months now
can I do that yes you can end of January
no end of January I'm [ __ ] gonna eat
a whole cow it's not that that's fine
but we [ __ ] this was a Blood Pact but
then don't say that I I can do whatever
I want because I can't yeah okay but if
I say that you're like halt you're such
a [ __ ] I already did nine days why did
you go pescetarian no just um just
wouldn't change i just ate like [ __ ] mmm
they can just extremely your body hasn't
changed either that's how you know you
can still eat [ __ ] up how do you
maintain this body start off like a
month
stop going crazy yes absolutely if you
saw him and you're at lace that you
described on to his physical appearance
pleasantly plump that no you're [ __ ]
fat I'm fine I'm fat